the Roy Moore campaign is on the rails
after another accuser emerges plus the
left finally acknowledged that Bill
Clinton is probably erasing a rapist but
they don't seem to acknowledge just why
they ignored it in the first place we'll
discuss all of it i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show okay so the
latest news is that Senate Republican
contender from Alabama Roy Moore was hit
with another allegation yesterday a very
credible allegation from a woman who is
now 55 years old she says when she was
16 years old Roy Moore essentially tried
to rape her we'll talk about that but we
will also talk about this this op-ed
from the New York Times the truly is
astonishing I think shows just why the
evil people in politics are gonna
continue to gain credibility and in
actually gain in in the public
consciousness as opposed to losing the
public consciousness it's an article
from the earth Times that's truly
astonishing tonight but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
zip recruiter so when we're looking to
fill a position over at the Daily wire
well let people know about it on Twitter
well let people know about it on
Facebook but we will also let people
know about it on zip recruiter because
zip recruiter is the best way to recruit
for a job with zipper query can post
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards with just one click
zip recruiter puts it smart matching
technology to work actively notifying
qualified candidates about your job
within minutes of posting so you receive
the best possible matches that's why zip
recruiter is different unlike other
hiring side zip recruiter does not
defend dependent on the right candidates
finding you it finds them instead 80% of
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site in
just one day zip recruiter is the
smartest way to hire and right now if
you go to zip recruiter dot-com slash
daily Wire my listeners can post jobs on
zip recruiter for free
so zip recruiter comm slash daily Wire
pretty special offer you can host your
job on zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire for free and that way you can get
all the qualified candidates coming
right through the front door you don't
have to worry about it clogging up your
email box instead you have a platform
that you can use in order to go through
those candidates it really is fantastic
zip recruiter comm slash daily Wire
check it out that also lets them know
that we set you okay so I want to start
with this article from New York Times
I'll get to the allegations against Roy
Moore in just a second but first I want
to give you the background because a lot
of people on the left
wondering why is it that so many people
on the right why is it that so many
people on the right are constantly you
know making excuses for bad behavior on
their own side this seemed like a a
question that was being asked a lot
during the last election cycle I asked
it too I said you know we were the party
that said the character mattered
we were the party that suggested that
that the President of the United States
should not be involved in sexual
misconduct and now we're nominating
Donald Trump and I thought that was an
open honest question but the reality is
that many people on the right as I
discussed yesterday are responding
directly to the left embrace of Bill
Clinton the bill clinton years broke the
country as far as the question as
whether character matters in their
politicians there are always two
perspectives on where the character
matter in politicians going all the way
back to the founding there is the
delegate version of representation and
there was the sort of responsibility
version of representation so the
delegate version of representation goes
like something like this the character
of the person you elect doesn't matter
so long as they do what you want and
this matter if they're a good person
doesn't matter if they're a smart person
so long as they are doing your bidding
you could elect a dog to basically hit a
button in the Senate and you'd be just
fine all right this is the delegate
model of representation then there's
what the founders thought Edmund Burke
philosopher John Stuart Mill thought
this that when you elect a
representative the whole point of having
a representative government as opposed
to a democratic government is that a
democratic government is all about the
idea that the people get to vote on
every issue a representative government
is about the idea the elect
representatives so you can delegate to
them the responsibility to do
independent thinking independent
research and come to their own
conclusions so that means you have to
trust the character of the people that
you actually elect this is why there's
an inscription on the Whitehouse from
John Adams that says may none but good
and wise men sit in this house
essentially the idea that character was
innately bound with good legislation was
something the founders really believed
it was part of American politics for
centuries that broke down during the
Clinton years because they're even
Clinton years they're been bad people
who were president before JFK was a bad
guy LBJ was a bad guy
all right there were lots of people who
were bad guys who were president before
but it had never been part of the public
consciousness just how disgusting some
of these politicians were the press did
not cover at all the allegations against
JFK instead they turned him into a white
knight on a shining horse and or
iron shining down a white horse or
whatever they're the phrases and in case
when Clinton came about and all the
allegations started to break about what
a disgusting person he was the left came
to his defense and what the left says
everyone lies about sex they said that
the accusers were a bunch of they were
and nuts right this was
legitimately a phrase that was used they
were a little bit not even a little bit
this was one of the things that
some of the Clinton defenders were
saying people like Nina Burleigh from
Time magazine she was saying that she
didn't care about Clinton's sexual
peccadilloes because she would be
willing to offer the president oral sex
so long as he kept abortion legal so
this is a very lowbrow way of saying
that it's the delegate model of
representation so long as he votes the
way I want it doesn't matter if the guy
is a complete scumbag
well now that logic has turned in on
itself for the Democrats because so many
people on the right are basically saying
the same thing now they're basically
saying who cares how ROI more votes
right this is the david horowitz
perspective or rather who cares how roy
more acts who cares if you tried to rape
a fourteen-year-old girl Luttrell who
cares if each a sexually assaulted a
sixteen-year-old none of that matters so
long as he votes the right way at
abortion and the left is objecting to
this I think rightly so so now what is
the left doing it responds well now the
left is trying to rewrite history
they're trying to explain why they
defended Bill Clinton but they think
that it's absolutely wrong to defend Roy
Moore or Donald Trump on their
allegations against them and so what
they've decided to do as their solution
is throw Bill Clinton under the bus but
defend their behavior at the time so
there's a piece by Michelle Goldberg at
the New York Times that is astonishing
and it's in its unconscious honesty
about how the left view to Bill Clinton
so I'm gonna go through it because I
think that this informs you want to know
why we are where we are in politics it
is because of things that happened when
I was a child it's because of the it's
because of the 1990s when the entire
political left decided the character no
longer counted and then the right
learned a lesson that if character no
longer counted it shouldn't count for
anybody so here is is what Michelle
Goldberg read she says on Friday evening
the MSNBC host Chris Hayes sends out a
tweet that electrified online
conservatives quote as gross and cynical
and hypocritical as the writes what
about Bill Clinton's stuff is it's also
true that Democrats and the central left
are overdue for a real reckoning with
the allegations against him he's as
sweet inspired stories on Glenn Beck's
the blaze Breitbart and The Daily Caller
all apparently eager to use the Clinton
scandals to derail the discussions about
Roy Moore the Republican nominee for the
US Senate in Alabama who's accused of
sexually assaulting minors well
that's not accurate that the right was
talking about Bill Clinton during the
Roy Moore stuff because they were trying
to dismiss allegations against Roy Moore
I was one of the first people to see the
road more should step out of the race
and I was mentioning Bill Clinton cuz I
was pointing out too hypocrisy of the
left in going after Roy Moore I was
saying that they should embrace his
standard where they throw Bill Clinton
overboard - and Ted Kennedy and JFK and
Harvey Milk and all the people who are
molesting you know young women all these
people should be thrown overboard by the
left if they hope wish to remain
consistent here the left doesn't wanna
remain consistence they're gonna accuse
us of hypocrisy even if I'm not a
hypocrite even if I think the Roy Moore
is guilty
in any case Michele Bloomberg continues
despite the rights evident bad faith I
agree with Hayes in this hashtag me to a
moment when we're reassessing decades of
male this behavior and turning open
secret syntax pose A's we should look
clearly at the credible evidence that
Juanita Broderick told the truth when
she accused Clinton of raping her slow
clap for coming to the correct
conclusion 25 years after the fact slow
clap for that
Juanita Broderick came out with her
allegations in like 1992 and she alleged
that Bill Clinton took her into a room
and forced himself on her and physically
raped her and then there was a dinner
afterward that she attended where
Hillary Clinton came up to her patted
her on the pan and she said thank you
for all you do me didn't keep her mouth
shut the left for two decades has been
ignoring Juanita Broderick and
pretending that Juanita Broderick didn't
exist during the last election cycle
when the Trump campaign brought up La
Nina Broderick the media quashed
interviews with Juanita Broderick they
said this is old news why would we cover
this only now when the elections are
over and when they're trying to look to
weaponize all sexual allegations against
the rights they finally admit that that
this stuff happened against Bill Clinton
Michelle Goldberg continues revisiting
the Clinton scandals in light of today's
politics is complicated as well as
painful it isn't complicated condemned
rapists condemned sexual assaulters I
have my entire career she says Democrats
are guilty of apologizing for Clinton
when they shouldn't have at the same
time and here here's where you start
getting the excuses here where you get
here's where you got the yeah sure we
crapped all over money to Broderick and
Paula Jones and Kathleen Willey and
Monica Lewinsky sure we we dumped heaps
of garbage on them and destroyed their
lives sure we did all the things but you
know why we did that we did that because
of the right
because the write was politicized that's
why we did it she has at the same time
looking back at the smear campaign
against the Clintons shows we can't
treat the feminist injunction to believe
women as absolutes the believe woman has
in quotes at her inner peace okay so the
idea here is that the smear campaign
against the Clinton means that you get
to crap all over a bunch of credible
allegations okay the same exact logic
what's hilarious is this article is
supposed to be kind of against more the
exact same logic could be used for Roy
Moore right the people who are defending
Roy Moore today say that this is a smear
campaign launched by The Washington Post
and left-wing media thirty days before
an election in order to get Roy Moore
that's the that's what they are alleging
so by her logic the right should look at
Roy Moore and say well maybe these
accusers are full of it I mean after all
this is a smear campaign from the left
obviously they're trying to win the
Senate seat it's amazing amazing even at
the same time they're throwing Bill
Clinton under the bus and now they can
throw Bill Clinton under the bus in
complete safety Hillary Clinton has lost
the presidency Bill Clinton is not the
first lady there that they can take his
desiccated political corpse and throw it
out the window of the Train no problem
whatsoever but even when they do that
they have to blame the right for it they
have to suggest that because the right
was trying to smear Clinton that bad
that these women should not be believed
it's an incredible statement it
demonstrates full scale the immorality
of the left on these particular issues
really amazing stuff writing it crooked
calm right Butler Bueller learns that in
future elections right when propaganda
will exploit the progressive commitment
to always taking sexual charges sexual
abuse charges seriously it's easy to
imagine an ally like Breitbart
leveraging the believe women rallying
cry to force mainstream media coverage
of dubious accusations wait a second
it's easy to imagine Breitbart doing
that it's easy to imagine Breitbart
doing that okay this is what the entire
right is accused or the entire right
accused the the media of doing with with
Donald Trump and Herman Cain and
Clarence Thomas and a bunch of other
Republican figures and now it's the
right-wing media that's gonna militarize
this the Clinton years
this piece continues in which a Piston
epistemological warfare emerged as a key
part of the Republican political arsenal
shows us why we should be wary of
allegations that bubble up from the
right-wing press so she starts off by
saying I believe one Neena Broderick and
then she defends eight paragraphs
explaining why she shouldn't have
believed Juanita Broderick fishes at the
time the reactionary billionaire Richard
melons
was bankrolling the Arkansas project
which David Brock the former right-wing
journalist who played a major role in it
described as the multi-million dollar
dirty tricks operation under the clinic
was even Brock the head of media matters
and now a multi-million dollar dirty
tricks operation against Republicans as
various figures in conservative media
accused Bill Clinton murder drug running
and using state troopers as pimps Barack
alleges that right-wing figures funneled
money to some of Clinton's accusers okay
does that mean that you can't believe
the accusers because what she seems to
be saying is you shouldn't believe them
so do you believe that Maddie I believe
them here's her here's what she
concludes in this environment it would
have been absurd to take accusations of
assault and harassment made against
Clinton at face value
really would have been absurd take one
Dida Broderick at face value would have
been absurd as a Paula Jones at face
value or Kathleen Willey at face value
when they made credible allegations of
rape and sexual assault when it was that
really that absurd because um no it
wasn't no it was not right she's she
says that Willie accused it not only
Bill Clinton of groping her and rubbing
his erect penis on her and pushing her
hand to his crotch but accused the
Clintons of having her husband and then
her cat killed must believe that too the
answer's no you don't have to believe
that allegation but you have to disprove
the other one right half that you have
to at least I thought that the idea
behind me too is that we have to at
least take seriously the other
allegation and she's then she dismisses
the Paula Jones stuff even though Bill
Clinton settled for hundreds of
thousands of dollars out of court she
says that Paula Jones's claim must have
been nonsense as well and then she
finishes this way this is amazing she
says of the Clinton accusers the one who
haunts me is Broderick the story she
tells about Clinton recalls those we've
heard about Weinstein
she claimed they plans to meet up in a
hotel coffee shop but the last minute he
asked to come up to her hotel room
instead where he raped her five
witnesses says she confided in them
mouthy assault right after it happened
it's true she denied the rape in
affidavits Paula Jones his lawyers
before changing her story when talking
to federal investigators but her
explanation that she didn't want to go
public but couldn't lie to the FBI make
sense put simply I believe her so buried
in this article about believing Juanita
Broderick is the fact that she thinks
Bill Clinton's a rapist but most of the
article is why it was okay not to
believe bill Clint was a rapist when the
allegations were made why because that
would have helped the right but she
concludes this way she says it's fair to
conclude that because of Broderick's
allegations Bill Clinton no longer has a
place in decent society okay if you
think that didn't he no longer have a
place in decent
25 years ago when he was running for
president seems to me rapists didn't
have a place in decent society in 1992
the same way they don't since 2017
because we should remember it's not
simply partisan tribalism that led
liberals to doubt her discerning what
might be true in a blizzard of lies
isn't easy and the people who spread
those lies don't get to claim the moral
high ground we should err on the side of
believing women but sometimes that
belief will be used against us
well then you're not erring on the side
of believing women are you I love that
line we should remember it's not simply
partisan tribalism that led liberals to
doubt her it was simply partisan
tribalism that led people to doubt
whadya Broderick that's what the entire
thing was about there is no question
that that is what the entire thing was
about and now they're accusing the right
of the same thing with some degree of
truth with some degree of truth but this
started on the left and then it infected
the right that doesn't mean the
infection on the right is okay it isn't
it's disgusting okay just because
somebody just because the left-hand
political herpes and now the right has
acquired political herpes does not make
political herpes good but to pretend
that this is something that's unique on
the right or the left it now has the
capacity to say they're herpes have been
cured at the same time they're defending
their acquisition of herpes to begin
with is disgusting okay before I go any
further we're gonna talk about Roy Moore
and what's happening with Roy Moore who
clearly needs to step down from this
race or we'll talk about that in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsor is over at saucy so if
all of this makes you feel like you need
a drink because I do
that's why you need saucy it's the
alcohol delivery app they deliver your
favorite wine beer and liquor right to
your door on demand it's lyft or uber
for alcohol we used it at my house a
couple of weeks ago we got some of the
the alcoholic apple cider which was
delicious and we also got some some
Irish cream and we got some whiskey we
really we really went all out it was
that kind of a week but in any case
saucy is a fantastic app they bring you
to your door like right your door within
half an hour it was really quick it was
very fast if you're if you're in LA San
Francisco Chicago San Diego Sacramento
it will arrive at your door in 30
minutes or less for the rest of us
Stassi will deliver beer wine and liquor
to your door in two days or less
nationwide no order minimums no delivery
fees no running to the store if you've
got the saucy app you've got a fully
stocked bar right there on your phones
here at a party and you've run out of
alcohol for your guests so you just you
put up the saucy app and you tell people
what to pick up you don't have to run
out from the party and ruin your night
instead somebody will deliver it
directly to your door and right now for
a limited time
we can get $15 off when you download the
saucy app and enter promo code Ben
that's again $15 off when you download
the saucy happenend for promo code Ben
sau Cey and supreme' Club Ben for $15
off get that saucy up today promo club
Ben gives you $15 off your purchase plus
it lets them know that we say you so
download the app and use that promo code
better okay so all of this leads up to
the latest allegations about Roy Moore
and the left is just in stitches over
this the left is chortling over the
Wonder and glory of the Roy Moore
allegations and that is because the Roy
Moore allegations are really bad okay so
we'll start with the the less disturbing
allegations right for this here's the
less disturbing allegation according to
the new yorker which has been doing good
work on the harvey weinstein stuff so
before everybody goes the new yorker is
just biased to the left and that's why
they're going after her Roy Moore they
also broke all of the news about harvey
weinstein here is what they say they say
that Roy Moore in the early 80s was a
regular visitor to the local Gadsden
Mall and he was banned from the mall he
they say that according to this
columnist he spoke or messaged with more
than a dozen people including a major
political figure in the state who told
me they had heard over the years that
Moore had been banned from them all
because he repeatedly badgered teenage
girls some say they heard this at the
time others in the years since these
people include five members of the local
legal community two cops who worked in
the town several people who hung out the
mall the early eighties and a number of
former mall employees the more campaign
did not answer requests for comments the
stories that say that they've been heard
for years have been swirling online for
days people were saying he was banned
from the gas terminal and the YMCA for
soliciting sex from young girls right
Theresa Jones the deputy da in Etowah
County
she told CNN last week it was common
knowledge that Roy dated high school
girls Greg Louganis 59 he was from 1981
to 1985 an employee at a store those in
the Gadson mall he said the mall was the
place to be he says he saw more than a
few times even though it was his
understanding that he'd already been
banned he said it started around 1979 I
know the band was still in place when I
got there he recalled the Gadsden police
officer named JD Thomas who worked
securing the mall he said JD was a
fixture there when I was working at the
store he really looked after the kids
there he was a good guy he said if you
see Roy let me know he's banned from the
mall okay people being banned from the
mall because they're trolling for
teenage girls that is not a good sign
and then it gets worse so yesterday
there was a lot of talk right before
during our
I told you about how Gloria Allred was
gonna be holding a press conference with
an accuser and and I suggested that
Gloria Allred's presence was was an
indicator that there may be a problem
with the story because Gloria Allred is
a publicity hound
then came the press conference and the
press conference was devastating the
press conference was devastating so here
is the you know here is the the press
conference itself the woman in this
story is a woman in Beverly young Nelson
she was 16 years old when the alleged
attempted near rape took place and here
she is describing what exactly happened
to do to her and then district attorney
Roy Moore instead of answering my
questions mr. Moore reached over and
began groping me him putting his hands
on my breast I tried to open my car door
to leave but he reached over he locked
it so I could not get out
I tried fighting him off while yelling
at him to stop but instead of stopping
he began squeezing my neck attempting to
force my head onto his crotch I
continued to struggle I was determined
that I was not going to allow him to
force me to have sex with him I was
terrified she was 16 years old at the
time and something that people should
know is that she liked the first 40
woman who accused
Roy Moore of sexually molesting her when
she was 14 years old she was a trump
supporter as well like everyone in
Alabama's Trump supporter so that
shouldn't come as any surprise to
anybody so these allegations are very
credible she also said that she knew Roy
Moore and she had proof that she knew
Roy Moore she said that she worked at a
restaurant until 10:00 p.m. at night and
basically it was very it was 10:00 p.m.
she got off shift her boyfriend couldn't
pick her up so Roy Moore offered to give
her a ride home
brought her in a car around the back of
the restaurant and then attempted to
force himself on her
she says that Roy Moore had frequented
this restaurant a lot and she said that
he actually asked to sign her yearbook
that there came a point where she was
where you know she had gotten her
yearbook and Roy Moore specifically
asked can I sign your yearbook and she
said yes and yesterday she actually
pulled out the yearbook and Roy Moore's
say
sure appears in that yearbook it looks
just like his signature from today
unless she went ahead and forged this
for no apparent reason it says to a
sweeter and more beautiful girl I could
not say Merry Christmas
so making Christmas great again right
more as Christmas 1977 love Roy Moore DA
so I actually signed it with his
position and then he signed it with the
date right 12 12 22 77 and then it said
Old Hickory house right so he even
signed the location Roy Moore's response
to all of this was to suggest that all
of this was was basically all of this
was nonsense that he didn't know her
there's a picture of her by the way you
can see there on the bottom you can see
the picture of her from her high school
yearbook and you know she was apparently
she competed in beauty pageants and
contests and such and more ease to come
in and flirt with her she says Roy Moore
responds it to all of us and here's Roy
Moore's response I want to make it
perfectly clear the people of Alabama
know me they know my character they know
what I've stood for in the political
world for over 40 years and I can tell
you without hesitation this is
absolutely false I never did what she
said I did I don't even know the woman I
don't know anything about her I don't
need to know where the restaurant is or
was and if you look at this situation
you'll see that because I'm 11 points
ahead or Ken or 11 points ahead this
race being just 28 days off this is a
political maneuver okay so he's gonna
blame it on a political maneuver and
exactly the same way that Michelle
Goldberg tries to blame not believing
the accuser as one Anita Broderick on
political maneuvering so you can see the
exact mirror logic of the Clinton years
is now being used by Roy Moore and one
of the things that this really you know
very difficult about this entire
situation is that everyone because
they're looking through these at these
allegations through the political lens
and it's impossible not to look at
through the political lens they are
they're now turning this into a battle
between the establishment and the non
establishment there's a report out today
the only major Republican who has not
disassociated from Moore in the
aftermath of those very credible
allegations that were made by this woman
yesterday literally the only Republican
who has not yet disassociated is Donald
Trump himself Trump is supposed to come
back into town I believe today and we
will see what he has to say apparently
according to Politico and sources around
the
he's actually tempted to support more in
spite of all of this which would not be
surprising even what we know of
president Trump's you know proclivities
in terms of bucking the the so-called
establishment turn this into an
establishment person anti-establishment
fight versus a don't support people who
against whom there are credible
allegations of child molestation that
that seems to me a wrong moral move a
very very bad moral move but again it
goes to the idea that everyone who
doesn't support where I'm or is
basically a establishment Aryan who
is willing to back down from the
Clintons and everybody who's willing to
fight is is willing to stand with Roy
more because the left is just so evil
and just so bad you're you're a wimp if
you don't stand with Roy more so you can
see this from Moore's coordinator in in
Alabama calling all of the Republicans
lightweights who are saying that he
should step down you're telling the
voters of Alabama if you choose your
senator that we are going to try to
nullify your vote therefore you don't
have constitutional right to vote in
Alabama because we are going to work our
best to nullify your vote if you vote
for Roy Moore that's the message I get
from that I don't know how you perceive
that but to say if the voters of Alabama
vote for Roy Moore you're all wrong and
I know more than you do as US Republican
senators know more than you do and we're
going to nullify your vote through some
kind of mechanism and the rules of the
Senate that's what we have from Senator
that's kind of a breach of the
Constitution that I don't think folks in
Alabama will rest well with okay so this
is what it's gonna turn into now now
it's gonna turn into it they're gonna
try to turn this into a battle between
establishment and non establishment over
an issue that really has nothing to do
with the establishment or non
establishment right good moral people
should look at allegations and see
whether they are credible or not and the
left has ignored this for 25 years and
the right is beginning to ignore it now
in response to the left like Shawn trend
from Real Clear Politics basically sums
this up incredibly well he says if you
don't understand the logic as to why so
many of these people seem to be okay
with what's going on with Roy Moore why
so many people seem to be backing away
from all of this you have to understand
that this is all born of the Clinton
years he says I don't sit up for the
ways I don't think you can underestimate
the degree to which many conservatives
have this attitude a we fought a battle
over whether character counts and got
our ass
tanda toss and be liberal leaders always
circle the wagons around their guys and
ours always cave right I think that's
exactly right I think it's the logic a
lot of people on the right are using I
think it's an immoral logic I think that
the left I did not actually win that
battle I think the reason george w bush
was elected president is because the
left didn't win that battle but i think
that there are a lot of people on the
right who believe that and so they're
gonna continue down this path where only
the real fighters are willing to stand
up for child rapists or alleged child
rapist okay i'm gonna continue along
these lines and talk about whether that
this is kind of misconception inside the
republican party that being a policy
hard-ass and being willing to to go
along with disgusting people are tied
together because there seems to be this
misconception that i think needs to be
separated out but i'm gonna talk about
that in just a second first i want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
real t-shirt so realty sheriff's comm is
the best place to invest in real estate
it's not an offering of securities
private investments are highly illiquid
and risky not suitable for all investors
past performance is not indicative of
future results securities offered to
accredited investors through north
capital private securities member finra
s ipeec but here's the deal if you are
looking to invest in real estate you
don't have a hundred thousand dollars
lying around to buy an apartment
building you just want to invest
incrementally in properties that have
been vetted by professionals so that
they are as a at least you know you're
not buying an empty lot in the middle of
nowhere
that is exactly what realty shares are
for it's a fantastic way to build wealth
ari alt why shares calm Realty shares
stock on hundreds of people invest
fractionally reducing the cost of an
initial investment Realty share deals
are vetted and curated by industry
professionals who under write and
perform detailed ii diligence so you
don't have to source investment
opportunities yourself it is free to
sign up and browse investments getting
set up takes just a few minutes i've
done it myself
and then you can manage and invest
straight from your phone or computer
through their simple and secure online
process all it takes is five thousand
dollars to make an investment and there
are no hidden fees if you make two
hundred thousand dollars a year you may
qualify find out today at realty shares
comm slash been
Realty shares comm slash been the way
that you get rich is by earning money
through your job and then investing it
wisely that's what Realty shares calm /
Ben is for and they have a special offer
just for my listeners go today to realty
shares common he had a hundred bucks for
your first investment again you get a
hundred bucks to your first investment
so now it's forty nine hundred bucks not
five thousand for your first investment
over at Realty shares are a lty shares
calm
/ Ben for $100 toward your first
investment again that's Realty shares
that comment / Ben that also lets them
know that we sent you which we always
appreciate okay so another more defender
was doing the same thing yesterday
basically suggesting that it's okay if
we're more has these accusations because
hey I think that Obama did cocaine and
people don't think Obama didn't cuz I
mean this seriously happened on
television last night is Brandon Mosely
he writes for a site called Alabama
political reporter and he said he
believes Roy Moore here was his defense
if you go back and you don't elect
anyone who's ever done anything wrong
we wouldn't have had Barack Obama I
think he did cocaine
Bill Clinton supposedly smoked marijuana
what okay so again this is the sort of
what about ISM is not good but the left
did it and so does the right and it's
it's really not a positive development
and I think again that it's being tied
to attitude so why do I think the Trump
is tempted not to throw Roy Moore under
the bus I think the reason he's tempted
not to throw under the bus is it seems
like the people who are most ardent
about throwing Roy Moore under the bus
are also the people who are anti Tea
Party and people who are anti Trump you
know the Jeff flakes in the world Jeff
Flake said he'd support a Democrat
before he supported Roy Moore know the
proper answer is you would support a
write-in candidate before you would
support Roy Moore or you would abstain
from voting that's the proper answer
Cory Gardner said if for one more wins
he should be should vote to be expelled
the Senate should vote to expel him but
the lead political figures have been
speaking out on this are the so-called
cuck people right the people who are
weak indeed there's been this time you
have to understand the entire Trump
movement is not built on policy it is
built on attitude and the attitude is
always a few to the left
okay that's always the attitude the
attitude is a giant middle finger and so
in this situation you can't say a few to
the left when the bad guy is in your own
party if you believe the allegations
against Roy Moore there's no fu to the
left here there's just a few - Roy Moore
right because you don't like people who
allegedly credibly molest 16 and 14 year
olds right that doesn't seem like a a
nephew to the left as much as immorality
as bad even when the left benefits or
could benefit I mean the fact is the
left is benefiting right now he's not
running 11 points up in Alabama he's
running dead even the cook Political
Report just moved to Alabama a Senate
race in which no no no
has been elected a Democrat from Alabama
since I believe 1994 has been a long
time and they just moved this race to
toss-up status that is because of Roy
Moore not because of folks like me in
any case the people who are speaking up
most strongly have been people who are
already politically opposed to more
rights it's people like Mitch McConnell
and Jeb Bush now I said I was very
discomforted with a lot of things about
Roy Moore but you know I thought that
Roy Moore's perspective on judicial
supremacy was not actually wrong that
said a lot of the people who are very
critical of Moore when these allegations
first broke were not necessarily
critical because of the allegations they
were critical because of politics so
Mitch McConnell came out yesterday he
said he believes the woman in Roy Moore
should step aside this is before the
second allegation came out where do you
believe these allegations to be true and
then Jeb Bush came forward and he said
the same thing he said that that that
Moore should step aside for decency we
saw the comments from Senator Mitch
McConnell about Roy Moore saying he
needs to step aside would you agree with
that I would I would because this is not
a question of innocence or guilt like in
a criminal proceeding this is a question
of what's right and what's wrong
and acknowledging that you're dating
teenagers when you're 32 years old as a
system of state attorneys we wrong it's
just plain wrong and do you think what
27 or so days left that if the GOP were
if mr. Moore were to step aside that
they would have the time to be
competitive in that Senate race I think
so I think so but more importantly we
need to stand for basic principles and
decency has to be one of those and again
the problem here is that there are so
many people on the right who now respond
to the tone and tenor more than they
respond to the information the real
question here is is Roy Moore credibly
alleged to have done these things do you
think he's guilty or do you think he's
not and if the only people who are out
there speaking on this are people like
McConnell and Bush this turns into a
proxy fight about attitude as opposed to
what it should be about this is my
biggest problem with politics in the in
the modern age politics in the modern
age seems to be almost entirely about
the attitudes that we attribute to the
other side as opposed to the facts on
the ground I don't care what's in jeb
Bush's head I don't care whether he
hates Roy Moore because Roy Moore is is
too fundamentalist I don't care whether
Mitch McConnell doesn't like Roy Moore
because he feels that he'd be a hassle
in the Senate the question to me is
whether Roy Moore should sit in the
Senate if he did these things and it
appears that he did right that's
question but instead we don't want to
answer the questions when you don't want
to answer a political question there's
an easy way to avoid answering a
political question this is true on both
sides you saw it in that Michelle
Goldberg column and you're seeing it now
from people who are supporting where I'm
or okay the there's the the question is
I don't want to answer a very simple
question are these allegations credible
if they are should he be in the Senate I
don't want to answer that question so
instead what I do is I say the
motivations of the people targeting Roy
Moore are questionable to me the
motivations right you go to motivation
that's what Michelle Goldberg does to
instead of saying were the allegations
of wanita Broderick credible 25 years
ago she's right
but the motivations of the people
leveraging those allegations were not
credible if we just go after each
other's motivations and we just
attributes one in other motivations
without any evidence because it's
convenient for us to do so that's how
bad things happen folks that's how bad
people get elected that's how Bill
Clinton ends up precedent that's how Roy
Moore despite credible allegations ends
up in the Senate okay if we just sit
around accusing each other of bad
motivations instead of making
independent moral judgments for
ourselves it absolves you of independent
moral judgment when you can just blame
the other guy for his motives right it's
it's one of the most disgusting things I
think about human beings just about
human nature it's something that we
ought to fight you know if somebody does
something that you think if if there's
in absolute moral question is it wrong
to steal and then instead of answering
the question is it wrong to steal you
say yes but the motivations of the
people condemning thievery I really
suspect they're religious
fundamentalists and I don't like that
then you're just avoiding answering the
question you are justifying your own
immorality by attributing motives to
somebody who you don't even know and
that's what I see happening so much and
so what this has resulted in is a
unconscious connection for many people
on both sides of the political aisle
between being radical on politics being
being you know being anti-establishment
on politics and being willing to go
along with bad guys because if you're
willing to go along with bad guys that
just shows that you're hard-nosed enough
to know that your that your opponents
are really nasty people who must
defeated be defeated by any means but if
you're hard-nosed enough on top if you
know the country is really in trouble
then you know that the left has bad
motivations and going after Roy Moore
and therefore it doesn't matter you
don't have to answer the question as to
whether Roy Moore is guilty or not this
is aim
I'll cop out it is a moral cop-out and
people who are engaging in it should
acknowledge that they are engaging in a
moral cop-out I'm not a Jeff Flake fan
okay I'm not a fan of Jeb Bush I would
not have voted from the primary and I
didn't I'm not a fan of Mitch McConnell
that does not change the basic question
did Roy Moore do it unless you can show
why you don't believe that he did it
credibly then I don't know why you would
support Roy Moore in this race
particularly when there's still time and
this by the way is an area I've talked
I've been critical of President Trump
intervening in particular races I felt
that he hasn't done enough in some cases
or that he's overstepped his boundaries
and others this could be an area where
Trump really demonstrates some
leadership what Trump needs to do with
Roy Moore right now his president Trump
needs to come out he said he needs to
say listen I didn't endorse write more
in the beginning I didn't endorse him he
as I thought he was a loser it turns out
that these allegations they kind of look
like he's a loser you shouldn't vote for
Roy Moore everybody should write in Jeff
Sessions right she'd tell his attorney
general run free or else he doesn't like
Jeff Sessions anyway he hates Jeff
Sessions sake he killed two birds with
one stone he should say everyone should
go out and vote for Jeff Sessions
tomorrow in the Alabama State Senate the
other thing that could happen right the
other thing that could be very easy to
do is I believe the other senator from
Alabama is Richard burr if I'm not
mistaken so you can say to Richard burr
I want you to drop out of your Senate
seat right now and run for the open
Senate seat in a in a write-in campaign
and then we'll have another special
election that doesn't involve all right
more for your Senate seat this is the
ari fleischer solution there are a
couple of solutions that are still on
the table but the longer Trump
dilly-dally around-- the longer Trump
refuses to say anything and if he just
comes out he says listen I think we're
more should step down but that's all
I've got to say on the matter
he's gonna need to do more than that he
needs to rally his base to vote for
someone who is not right more because
otherwise you're gonna end up with a
split vote and as much as people in
Alabama there's a base of people who
like Roy Moore and are and have
allegiance to Roy Moore many more people
in Alabama have allegiance to Donald
Trump than have allegiance to Roy Moore
this is one area that we're where Trump
really could make an outsized difference
in the wake of allegations like this
like he wasn't able to he wasn't able to
arrange people behind Luther strange and
I don't think II should try to at this
point but I do think that he should stop
I do think that he should he should
leverage his capacity to try and replace
Roy Moore with somebody who is more
palatable but I don't think that he
should do is continue along lines laid
out by representative Mel Brooks the
David Horowitz line even if he did it
I'll be revolting for Roy Moore here's
Brookes making exactly that case he says
America faces huge challenges that are
vastly more important than contested
sexual allegations from four decades ago
who will vote in America's best
interests on Supreme Court justices
deficit and debt economic growth border
security national defense and the like
socialist Democrat Doug Jones will vote
wrong Roy Moore will vote right hence I
will vote for Roy Moore okay that's the
delegate model of representation vote
for a person who may rape children so
long as he votes right on the issues I
think that Trump needs to fight against
this but MIT but you know I have my
doubt that character will ever if we may
have reached the breaking point for
character American Life where we've just
decided the character legitimately
doesn't matter in American life anymore
that would be a very very sad point okay
I want to get to what I think it's a
giant nothing burger about Donald Trump
jr. in just a second but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
ProFlowers so my wife is obsessed with
the season of fall she really enjoys
fall and the perfect gift for for her I
like to get her random gifts is a fresh
bouquet in fall colors I mean I'm a big
autumn fan and their fall colors
bouquets over from Florida from
ProFlowers look fantastic the quality of
flowers is really tremendous i order her
bouquet the other day and legitimately
the same time somebody came over for
dinner and brought some roses from the
local grocery store within four days the
the roses from local grocery store
already falling apart the ones from
ProFlowers stayed good for at least a
week they were just beautiful their best
selling cinnamon cider roses are a great
option for birthday and anniversary any
fall occasion or go with one of the
classics like 100 autumn blooms or a
dozen autumn roses you can't lose
because no matter which bouquet you send
my listeners get 20 percent off of any
ProFlowers unique bouquets of 29 dollars
or more 20 percent off of any ProFlowers
unique bouquets of 29 bucks or more and
they are guaranteed to stay fresh for at
least seven days or your money back you
control the delivery date they come in a
box they're well packed and they give
you instructions on how to keep the
flowers fresh they really are gorgeous
get 20% off all bouquets of $29 or more
go to proflowers.com use promo code
Ben's show at checkout that's promo code
Ben's show at checkout and you get 20%
off of their unique bouquets of 29
dollars or more again it's
proflowers.com
and use that code Ben show at checkout
okay so meanwhile the media are
completely off the rails about this new
report that suggests that Donald
Jr was messaging with WikiLeaks I don't
think there's a lot here I really don't
think that there's very much here at all
you can see that CNN was going nuts over
this they were suggesting that this just
demonstrates that active collusion took
place no and I will explain in just a
moment according to new reporting in the
Atlantic magazine three full weeks
before running mate Mike Pence denied
the campaign was quote in cahoots with
WikiLeaks Donald Trump jr. was
absolutely in touch with you guessed it
WikiLeaks WikiLeaks you'll recall was
the organization of the US intelligence
community believes was chosen by the
Kremlin to spread hacked information
damaging the Hillary Clinton the
Democrats what is so fascinating is how
the communications in the form of
Twitter direct messages meshed with
certain points on the campaign timeline
that we already know quite well for
instance October 2nd Trump friend and
former adviser Roger stone tweets the
damaging material is coming from
WikiLeaks
the next day October 3rd from jr.
messages them asked them what's coming
on the fifth stone says there is a
payload coming from WikiLeaks on the 7th
the US intelligence community says it
believes Russia was behind the dnc hacks
and WikiLeaks begins releasing the
hacked DNC Podesta emails a month later
the 12th October WikiLeaks messages
Trump jr. asking him to link to one of
their items two days later he tweets it
out and on that same day the 14th Mike
Prince denies any collusion with
WikiLeaks it is to say at the least
fascinating okay so this idea that there
was some sort of deep-seated collusion
going on unfortunately the the record
sort of belies this so according to the
Atlantic according to a source familiar
with the congressional investigations
into Russian interference with the 2016
campaign who requested anonymity because
the investigation is ongoing run the
same day the Trump jr. received the
first message from WikiLeaks he mailed
to other senior officers with the Trump
campaign including Bannon Conway Brad
Parr scale and Trump son-in-law Jared
Kushner telling them WikiLeaks had made
contact Kushner then forwarded the email
to campaign communications staffer hope
X and no point during the 10-month
correspondences Trump jr. rebuffed
WikiLeaks okay does this show
deep-seated collusion does this show
deep-seated collusion I will explain why
not in just a moment but first you're
gonna have to go over today Lee Weyer
calm and subscribe for $9.99 a month you
can subscribe to daily wire.com to get
the rest of my show live on video you
get the rest of Michael Noel's
live on video get the rest of Andrew
Clavin show live on video he got to be
part of my mailbag when we have
conversations well you get to be part of
the mailbag for that too so you get to
ask us questions that make your life
better plus if you get the you get the
$99 a year annual subscription to get
this the very greatest in all leftist
here's hot or cold tumblers they are
just fantastic they are the greatest
thing that you have ever seen in the
history of humanity I was at UCLA last
night actually and a bunch of people
said that they had bought the mug
because they'd subscribed thank you for
subscribing and they are enjoying it in
in outsized fashion now by the way our
next conversation is happening today at
5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific featuring
the the incomparable Michael Noel's
Michael's conversation will stream live
on the Taylor our website Facebook page
and YouTube channel it's free for
everyone to watch only subscribers can
ask questions subscribe today and ask
Michael questions and join the
conversation first question you should
ask him why is it okay for you to make
hundreds of thousands of dollars off a
blank book on which the only
recommendation has been Shapiro's and
Shapiro made no money off of it that
should be number one question I will
subscribe to daily wire just to ask
Michael Mills that question also if you
just want to listen to the rest of the
show later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud or YouTube subscribe leave us
a review we always appreciate it we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast on planet Earth
[Music]
I added the on planet earth and not just
in the nation because I was informed by
a viewer that there's no other
conservative show on planet earth that
is as big as ours so that I think that
that is worth noting that is not like
somebody broadcasting from Hong Kong
that's that's conservative and larger
okay so why is it that this Donald Trump
junior Russian operative story doesn't
really work first of all we already knew
that Donald Trump jr. was happy to work
with WikiLeaks okay we already knew that
Donald Trump jr. and the Trump campaign
we're happy to reach out to the Russian
government we know that because Donald
Trump treater basically admitted that he
told the Russian government connected
actor months ago that he loved the idea
of coordinating on Hillary Clinton Oppo
the head of Cambridge analytical which
was the data operation for the Trump
campaign reached out directly to
WikiLeaks to ask for material from
Hillary's private server does that mean
the collusion actually took place no
okay so here is the actual
correspondence on September 21st 2016
WikiLeaks let Trump jr. know it had
guessed the password to an anti-trump
web site from Florida Trump jr.
forwarded that info to campaign
officials that was the end of it on
October 3rd 2016 WikiLeaks asked Trump
jr. to retweet something Trump Trump jr.
already had tweeted it on October 14th
2016 Trump jr. tweeted out a link from
WikiLeaks that they had sent him via
direct message he probably would have
anyway the rest of the correspondence is
WikiLeaks asking for stuff from Trump
and Trump refusing to even respond they
asked for Trump's tax returns and Trump
jr. did not even respond to that is this
earth-shattering stuff does this
demonstrate full-scale collusion to tip
the election to Hillary Clinton no of
course not that's in that's how it
demonstrates at all it demonstrates
again willingness but we know about the
willingness so nothing has actually
changed here
nothing has actually changed in any
serious way so you know I'm not sure why
this is such a it seems like a giant
nothing burger to me to me to be quite
frank okay time for some things I like
things I hate and then we'll deconstruct
the culture so things that I like when I
first there there very few movies where
I try watching them once I hate them and
then I go back later and I rewatched
them and I really like them in fact this
may be the only movie like that that I
can think of so a few years back I tried
watching the assassination of Jesse
James by the Coward Robert Ford and I
thought man this thing is just slow I
mean it is it is a slow movie there's no
question it is a slow movie and it's in
there's a narrator which I generally
don't like in films
and I watched it again this week I only
gotten through I think the first half an
hour or the first time I got through the
entire movie this time it did take me
two days but I did get through the
entire movie it is free from Amazon
Prime I believe and it is and it is
actually not just a good movie it's a
very good movie it's it's a beautifully
shot movie Brad Pitt who cannot act is
quite good in this Casey Affleck was
nominated for Best Supporting Actor now
he may be an utter scumbag as a human
being there are all these allegations
about him mistreating limit but he's a
terrific actor talent falls on the good
and the evil alike he is a really
first-rate actor and his performance is
Robert Ford in this is really quite good
and quite tragic it is it is a very
complex story about why Jesse James is
sort of worshipped by the American
public even though Jesse James is really
a terrible person and but even Jesse
James is a shaded character it's it's
really really interesting and it's got
so many great character actors that the
cast of this thing is really fantastic
so I mean it's I was I was looking at
the cast the other day it was um I'm
trimmin Wells's in this Sam let's see
mary-louise Parker plays Brad Pitt's
wife she sort of has a bit part the
Casey Affleck Sam Rockwell plays Charlie
Ford who's Robert Ford's brother a
jeremy renner is in it playing wood
height before Jeremy Renner was anything
big Sam Shepard plays Frank James and
he's terrific garret dillahunt who's
really one of the the kind of underrated
character actors of our time he also
plays two parts on Deadwood he's in it
Paul Schneider plays dick little and he
is terrific in it so there's this really
great kind of character actors and and
the movie itself is is really I think
quite good and demonstrates that good
and evil have shades to them so a good
movie really worth a watch okay other
okay time for a thing that I hate
okay so the the left has decided that a
guy named Brett Talley should certainly
not sit on the on a federal court in
Alabama now I have some objections to
this simply because I know Brett so
Brett and I are friends we were friends
at Harvard Law School and the idea that
what what they're trying to what they're
trying to do to him is basically bring a
bunch of random information and suggest
that it is indicative of a crazy guy
okay that is not true Brett is a very
down-to-earth solid conservative
constitutional conservative we were
classmates at Harvard Law School here in
Federalist Society together here is his
record because they're saying he's never
actually tried a case he's never tried a
case okay first of all transactional
lawyers don't always try cases right
transactional there many transactional
lawyers who are judges
and never tried a case that's number one
number two clerking for judges is a
credential for becoming a judge you
don't have to be a trial lawyer in order
for you to sit on a courts that's the
stupid criticism early in his career
he's an associate at Gibson Dunn &
Crutcher which is one of the top law
firms in the country he's a law clerk to
Joel's beena on the US Court of Appeals
for the Eleventh Circuit and he's a
logged clerk to Judge Scott Kugler of
the of the Northern District of Alabama
he works for the DOJ he went to Harvard
Law School he was the articles editor
for the Harvard journal of law and
public policy which is sort of the
conservative journal over there
he was a speechwriter for Rob Portman
and a senior writer for Mitt Romney's
presidential campaign and he's published
what the left is now jumping on as
they're saying well he was a member of a
true ghost-hunting committee he writes
ghost stories like he's been nominated
for the Bram Stoker award he write so he
writes horror novels which is actually
kind of cool but I guess we're supposed
to crap all over and because an
interesting guy now they're suggesting
that his that he's not qualified because
he has never tried a case and the ABA of
course you've rated him not qualified to
be on the federal judiciary they have
also rated a bunch of conservative
people not qualified he he quote/unquote
displayed a degree of partisanship
unusual for a judicial nominee on his
blog he denounced Hillary Clinton is
Hillary rotten Clinton so I guess that
if you opposed Hillary Clinton and think
that she's rotten you're no longer
qualified to sit on a federal court and
said you have to pretend that she's
wonderful
and he expressed support for the NRA oh
no oh no no other judges have ever
supported the NRA I am sure just asinine
you know the idea that you can't have
political opinions and sit on a federal
court has always been an issue for me
because it only applies to one side of
the political aisle Ruth Bader Ginsburg
can work for the can work for now for
years and that's totally fine you know
she can give speeches on a routine basis
excoriating the right and excoriating
Trump and that's cool but Brett Talley
he commented on a blog about politics
that means that he can't be a judge
they're also saying you know how dare he
failed to disclose that he was married
to Anna Donaldson who's the chief of
staff the White House Counsel Don Magan
saying that that is a conflict of
interest Talley didn't mention his wife
on describing his contact with lawyers
for the White House yes I'm sure he was
trying to I'm sure he was trying to hide
that I'm sure he really thought he was
gonna get away with his wife works for
the government and again the idea that
it's an oversight seems slightly more
palatable maybe but it just demonstrates
that we do this routine now that's
really really dumb and really irritating
where we pretend that judges have no
political proclivities whatsoever the
question is will he make a good judge
I know Brett I know his constitutional
philosophy he will make a better judge
than any of the people on the Left who
are currently sitting on the Supreme
Court of the United States so you know
this is this is a wild overreach on the
part of the left but that's nothing new
okay weird guy didn't deconstruct the
culture so I'm gonna do a very very
brief deconstruction of the culture this
week I know a lot of people were excited
about me deconstructing the song
rockstar by post Malone so post Malone
is a white guy who does sort of rap
reggae I guess he follows me on Twitter
so thanks for following post but here is
a bit of his song rockstar
[Music]
okay so this is this is pretty typical
kind of rap it's sort of reggae slash
rap so the lyrics to this thing are all
about effing hoes and poppin Pili's man
I feel like a rock star my brother's got
that gas they always be smoking like a
Rasta effing with me call up on the Uzi
and show up man them shot eyes I see the
shotguns when my homies pull up on your
block they make that thing go gratata
okay so this is not my favorite stuff as
you know and whenever I analyze rap
genre rap and R&B genre very often it's
it's to critique this particular aspect
of the culture the glorification of
drugs and violence and an effing hos
it's amazing that an entire genre of
music is allowed to talk about women
this way and and meanwhile we're
supposed to pretend that it's that it's
okay right well we've decided as a
society this kind of stuff is not to be
said about women except if you're
recording these kinds of songs but what
does the left upset about are they've
set about the contents of this either
they've said about the drugs and the
effing hoes and the shooting people
stuff no they're not upset about any of
this what they are her what they are
upset about is cultural appropriation
because you see post Malone is white
okay this is from the LA Times circa
December he's a white culture vulture
call cynically appropriating
african-american culture he's received
more attention than his meager talent
deserves he's a rich kid who's his
parents essentially paid his way into
music he says there's a thing that says
they bought 50,000 my songs on iTunes
apparently his hit single is white
Iverson he says my dad's not a baller I
have no idea where to get the money for
that what I find it interesting about
the left is that they're very upset
about the cultural appropriation that
postman alone is is apparently engaging
in by taking tropes from rap and using
them being a white guy from an
upper-middle class background I suppose
here is my problem with that I too am
upset with cultural appropriation of bad
in culture okay I don't think anyone
should be appropriating thing about
effing hoes and blowing people away so
post Malone may be very talented but to
to critique him on the basis of cultural
appropriation is an astonishing thing
right so the problem here is that if you
were black you would be okay but he's
white so it's not okay for him to say
these things one of the problems with
rap culture is that these things are
present in the first place if you want
to correct to this if you don't want
people culturally appropriate in garbage
maybe you shouldn't make garbage for
people to culturally appropriate how
about we start with that the problem
here is not that post Malone is white
the problem is that the message that
he's promoting in the song is the same
as the message that's promoted
throughout the rap community and
apparently without which you cannot rise
to the top of the R&B rap charts okay
that's the problem here so you know I
wish that he would use his talents to
promote better messaging and if he's
gonna culturally appropriate you know
appropriate the musical stylings if you
wish but please don't culturally
appropriate the worst aspect of an R of
a rap culture that glorifies stuff like
this it doesn't make it okay okay so we
will be back here tomorrow with lots
more I'm sure on the political scene
we'll be broadcasting from New York
tomorrow I'm going to be on Fox and
Friends live tomorrow and also going to
be the one lucky gentleman on
outnumbered tomorrow so I will see you
from live from New York tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]